you really are your only comparison
group especially as you get older
because your life is so idiosyncratic
and peculiar that
any compare i mean look you have to care
what other people think it's stupid to
think otherwise
because you have to be social and you
have to be aware of what other people
are doing and all of that so
it's this is psychopathic individual
individuality
but it is genuinely true that no one has
your set
of opportunities and limitations
and so the the comparison just isn't
real it can't be sufficiently
multi-dimensional
you know because maybe you see someone
who's re i've dealt with i've
i've met many people who are very very
rich and
you can look at their lives and they
have these huge houses and
material plenty but j and they're
shielded from
many catastrophes that would hit someone
without those resources harder
but their lives are still full of
exactly the same troubles
that characterize human life in general
and
so you you compare yourself on one
dimension you don't see well the
person's worked 80 hours a week for 40
years and it's blown all his
relationships out of the water
it's like yes he's rich but he's also
old now
you know he's 60 and one of the best
predictors of wealth is age
you know really do you want to be young
and poor or old and rich
it's like i'd pick young and poor
because you can't buy youth
and so and that's something that's worth
considering but you don't know what
burdens the people you're
jealous of are carrying
so leave it be
it's not it's not helpful to you to to
to be envious
i often tell people that we don't know
the price that you need to pay
to be the people that you admire so we
look at elon musk or conor mcgregor or
kim kardashian
and we want the success that they have
within a very narrowly defined domain of
competence
tiger woods fantastic example the
greatest
golfer ever but his dad mistreated him
so much as a kid that they had a safe
word
they had a safe word like you do during
rough sex that tiger could tell him
if he'd had enough and it was called the
e-word it was enough and tiger never
once said it
his dad would racially abuse him while
he was on the golf course telling him
that these white people are never going
to let you on here
but then when we look at tiger's golf
game
only then can we even begin to see what
kind of looks a bit
like child abuse but only when he's
able to perform in that way but the
question is would you pay
that price to be tiger woods
would you have so little self
belief outside of the golf game that you
have the most public marriage failure
that anyone's ever seen
he's on anti-psychotic drugs and being
pulled over by police at the side of the
road
because he's fallen asleep at the wheel
he's spent half a decade
off the game because he's been injured
because of how hard he's pushed himself
do you really want that
because that's the price you have to pay
to be tiger woods
you can't just get the golf capacity
without having
everything that comes with it this isn't
pick and choose like clothes off a rail
this is a wholesale sale you pick
everything
warts and all you need to pick their
sleep patterns their
self-body image all of the genetics
they've got the way that their brain
feels when they go to bed at night a lot
of people i think if they were able to
see the full package
they wouldn't pay that price yeah
and and that could well be the right
decision
no who who knows what price you pay for
hyper specialization
you know and i learned that looking at
you know
power mad c-suite types well first of
all they're generally not power mad
because power is actually an
unbelievably unstable way of
establishing
authority you you get you get
slaughtered if you're not reciprocal in
most reasonably functioning
organizations
and if you're in an organization that
only rewards the
exercise of power the probability that
that organization is going to
fail in totality is
extraordinarily high because it's a
tyrannical organization it'll lose touch
with its customers
so the c suite types um
they're they're working non-stop
corporate lawyers in new york you know
they make 700 an hour
but they work all the time all the time
and there are people who are suited for
that
but it isn't obvious that that's
for everyone or that it should be or
that it's even
desirable now it's a temperamental issue
to a large degree
you know many of those people are hyper
conscientious
and so if they they'll work whatever you
put them what they would do is work
that's who they are and it's biological
as well
it's you know it's not all biological
because traits are affected by
learning and by environment in complex
ways but a huge chunk of it is
that you're born like that and that has
advantages and disadvantages
so conscientiousness is a good example
um
it's a good predictor of long-term life
success
but people are conscientious tend to
tear themselves apart if they become
unemployed for example
you know sometimes you get laid off you
worked hard but you get laid off
well people who are conscientious will
tear themselves into pieces
with guilt in that situation because
they tend to attribute
so much responsibility to themselves and
so there's a price to be paid for
conscientiousness it it opens you up
to a certain set of vulnerabilities so
you know and you might be somewhat
unbearable to your family too because
all you ever do is work
you know you think well you you want to
be a good you want your father
maybe your husband perhaps your wife to
be a good provider but
you want them to do that at the expense
of everything else
generally no thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy
peace
you